[Música]
hace un tiempo mientras caminaba para la
escuela
me pasa lo desagradable para no entrar
en detalles y porque la verdad
básicamente no es nada que no le pase a
la mayoría de las mujeres un tipo se
sintió con la total libertad de
mostrarme su miembro
pensando que tal vez era una buena idea
en este momento me asusté pero también
edite pero qué [ __ ] haces [ __ ]
[Aplausos]
y camine rápido a la cuadra que me
faltaba
ya en el aula me senté y le conté a una
compañera
me pregunto si estaba bien y quedó todo
ahí porque aunque me estuviese muriendo
de bronca
qué más podía hacer
nada
la realidad es que comparándolo con
cosas que le pasaron a mis amigas como
que te quieran subir a un auto y tener
que correr para escaparte o que te manos
en la calle lo que me había pasado a mí
era relativamente insignificante por
suerte pero fue suficiente como para
hablar un poco paranoica y hacer que me
parecieron a una idea empezar a andar
por la calle con un cúter
por las dudas
el acoso entre tantos otros temas eso
que pasaba y que todo el mundo sabía qué
pasaba estaba ahí pero de lo que por ahí
no se hablaba o se le restaba
importancia
hoy en día sin embargo tanto este tema
como otras cuestiones tienen una mayor
visibilidad
en parte porque hay cosas que ya no se
aceptan como si antes si las hubiésemos
aceptado
pero sobre todo porque las jóvenes y los
jóvenes en general contamos con un
espacio en donde podemos manifestar lo
que nos pasa tomar la palabra y generar
de alguna manera difusión
y lo que es todavía más importante apoyo
reacción y organización si lo pensamos
en las redes que estamos participando
todo el tiempo le doy me gusta la foto
que subió un amigo voto en la encuesta
que hace a alguien que sión instagram
que por ahí ni conozco de mi opinión
acerca de una noticia que publicó un
medio en twitter
tenemos una herramienta para expresarnos
para informarnos y construir nuestras
opiniones acerca de las cosas que pasan
para manifestar nuestras
reivindicaciones reivindicaciones que
tarde o temprano exceden ese espacio y
terminan en una calle o en una plaza
el año pasado por ejemplo en berazategui
donde yo vivo un par de pies convocaron
una movilización
lo hicieron por numerosos testimonios
que serían viralizado en redes de chicas
gran de la zona y que dan paso a
situaciones bastante feas desde acoso
hasta violencia o abuso
así fue como un sábado a eso de las 4 de
la tarde nos juntamos cientos de mujeres
en la plaza
yo fui para apoyar fui por mí porque me
pasa
pero también fue como una manera de
decirles a todas esas chicas que se
habían expuesto contando lo que habían
vivido que les creía que no estaban
solas
y es re loco pensar que durante mi
infancia los programas que mirábamos
todas las letras de sus canciones
hablaban siempre de una especie de
enemistad o competencia entre mujeres
nadie pasa de esta esquina aquí mandan
las divinas
fuera frías fuera frías para ustedes no
hay lugar
pero en que estaban pensando
con los ojos de hoy la verdad es que
esta letra me parece un poco horrible
con todo esto me di cuenta que había
cosas que por mucho tiempo se habían
entendido como privadas pero que ahora
irrumpían en el espacio público y que al
hacerlo habrían la posibilidad de
generar un cambio
me gusta mi generación
me gusta porque creo que entendimos que
movernos es la única forma de potenciar
ese cambio poniendo sobre la mesa lo que
nos pasa lo que no nos gusta y diciendo
mira esto hay que discutirlo acá hay que
hacer algo
lo que me pasó a mí yendo al colegio
quizás
quizás no se puede evitar
pero por lo menos ahora sé que hay algo
que puedo hacer
ya sea por temas de acoso cambio
climático o cualquier otro somos un
montón los y las jóvenes dispuestos a
usar las redes para darle visibilización
a lo que queremos decir pero solo para
después poner el cuerpo y accionar
porque creo que esa es la única forma de
hacernos ver e instalar el debate
hoy tejer esas redes de contacto con un
otro que piensa parecido o no que está
igual de indignado y que está dispuesto
a hacer algo a discutir es un poco más
fácil
la sociedad está cambiando cosas que
antes mirábamos con recelo al menos hoy
estamos dispuestos a sacarlas del cajón
en el que estuvieron por mucho tiempo
para mostrarlas y para discutirlas
y aunque quizás todavía falte mucho por
hacer
ojalá que en un futuro ni a mí ni a
nadie nos parezca que es una buena idea
tener que salir a la calle con un cúter
pero si tener que salir a la calle para
luchar por aquello en lo que creemos
gracias
y
[Aplausos]